Remember in lesson three how we stored the friends of a person? We had an
instance variable friends, and when we added friends, we added their names to
the friends instance variable. To remove friends, we replaced their names, with
an empty string. What if I decided to add some methods that comment on the
number of friends a person has? And try to use these conditions. Match each
condition to a description of its error. The errors are; strings are objects
and should be compared using equals. The strings friends will never be null.
Loss of precision may prevent this condition from being true even when a person
would see that it should be true. And this if statement tries to change the
value of the variable instead of comparing it.